GO TO D.C. AND CHECK IN WITH
TUCKER CARLSON COMING UP
NEXT.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE COMMERCE DEPARTMENT
TODAY ANNOUNCED CHANGES TO
THE CENSUS.
ORDINARILY THAT WOULD NOT BE
A VERY BIG DEAL.
STARTING IN TWO YEARS
RESPOND DENTS WILL BE ASKED
IF THEY ARE U.S. CITIZENS.
THAT QUESTION HAS BEEN ASKED
ON CENSUS FORMS IN YEARS
PAST AND OBVIOUS QUESTIONS
FOR ASKING IT.
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES IT IS
TO APPORTION CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICTS SO AMERICANS WITH
CAN VOTE FOR
REPRESENTATIVES.
ONLY U.S. CITIZENS ARE
ALLOWED TO VOTE IN FEDERAL
ELECTIONS SO IT MIGHT BE
NICE TO KNOW HOW MANY LIVE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SOUND REASONABLE TO YOU?
EVEN BORING?
ARE YOU STILL AWAKE.
IF NOT YOU ARE NOT A
PROFESSIONAL OUTRAGE
MERCHANT.
THE LEFT CAME CLOSE TO
LOSING CONSCIOUSNESS TODAY
OVER THIS IDEA.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA JAVIER BECERRA
SAYS HE WILL CHOOSE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OVER
THIS CHANGE.
BECERRA SAYS ASKING PEOPLE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
CITIZENS IS SOMEHOW
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
WATCH.
>> GIVEN THE WAY THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAD ATTACKED
IMMIGRANTS, YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES WOULD BE AFRAID TO
FILL OUT THE CENSUS
QUESTIONNAIRE.
IN OUR LAWSUIT WE ARGUE THIS
DECISION BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION VIOLATES THE
CONSTITUTION AND FEDERAL
LAW.
>> Tucker: WELL ARI BURMAN
OF JAVIER MAGAZINE.
HE GOT SO WORKED UP ABOUT
THE CENSUS QUESTION HE
DESCRIBED THE CHANGE AS,
QUOTE:  A HUGE CRISIS FOR
DEMOCRACY.
OH, COME ON.
NOBODY ACTUALLY BELIEVES
THAT NOBODY BELIEVES THE
LINES LIKE THAT EVEN THE
RED-FACED PEOPLE WHO SCREAM
THEM.
THE LEFT DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
WHAT IS OR WHAT IS NOT
DID YOU WATCH THE GUN MARCH
THIS WEEKEND?
OBVIOUSLY THEY DON'T CARE.
A CRISIS FOR DEMOCRACY?
IF YOU REALLY CARED ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, REPRESENTATIVE OF
DEMOCRACY, YOU WOULD BE
VIGILANT ABOUT PREVENTING
VOTER FRAUD THE LEFT ABETS
IT IN STATE AFTER STATE
INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA SO
ILLEGALS GET DRIVERS LICENSE
SO THEY CAN REGISTER TO
VOTE.
DEMOCRACY, PLEASE.
THEY HATE THE FACT YOU TOOK
SOME OF THEIR POWER BY
VOTING FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WANT IT BACK BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
OBVIOUSLY.
CAESAR VARGAS AN ATTORNEY
AND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
HE JOINS US.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: COUNTING CITIZENS
ASKING WHETHER THEY ARE
CONTINUES HOW COULD THAT BE
CONSTITUTIONAL WHEN THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES YOU
COUNT YOUR CITIZENS?
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVES ARE ALL ABOUT
THE ORIGINAL INTENT, THE
FOUNDING MEANING OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
WELL, THE CONSTITUTION
EXPLICITLY STATES THAT WE
NEED AN ACTUAL ENUMERATION.
IN OTHER WORDS, AN ACTUAL
COUNT OF THE WHOLE PERSONS
IN EACH STATE.
NEVER SAID ANYTHING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
NEVER SAID ANYTHING.
THE PURPOSE IS TO COUNT
EVERYONE IN THE UNITED
STATES REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
SO THAT'S PERFECT.
AS A PERSON OF WHO APPROVES
OF ORIGINAL INTENT, YOU
WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
WE WOULD NEED TO COUNT
EVERYTHING AND ABIDE BY THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
>> CONSTITUTION AT THIS
MOMENT.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU ARE
LECTURING ME ON THE
CONSTITUTION.
BUT DOES THIS CHANGE, SAY,
THAT YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
COUNT PEOPLE WHO ARE
NONCITIZENS?
NO.
IT SAYS TAKE A COUNT.
IT'S ONE OF THE MANY
QUESTIONS.
THE CONSTITUTION BY THE WAY
SINCE I KNOW YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH IT DOESN'T SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT COUNTING
PEOPLE BY RACE.
THE CENSUS DOES THAT.
SHOULD WE NOT ASK WHAT
PEOPLE'S RACE.
>> UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION
WE HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR
ABOUT IT'S ABOUT TARGETING
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, SLOW
DOWN.
WAIT, HOLD ON.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET YOU
READ YOUR BUMPER STICKER.
STOP, STOP YOU, STOP.
I WANT YOU TO ANSWER MY
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT THE
CENSUS FORM OUGHT TO BE ABLE
TO ASK PEOPLE WHETHER THEY
ARE HERE ILLEGALLY OR
CITIZENS OR NOT.
OKAY.
YOU DO THINK IT OUGHT TO BE
ALLOWED TO ASK THEM WHAT
THEIR GENETIC MAKEUP IS?
WHAT THEIR RACE IS?
WHY?
>> WE SHOULD HAVE A VERY
SIMPLE DOCUMENT THAT SAYS
HEY, HOW MANY PEOPLE LIVE IN
YOUR HOME.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN THE
FATE?
I THINK THAT'S SIMPLE.
I'M NOT PUTTING ASIDE THE
POLITICS ABOUT.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET YOU
DODGE IT A THIRD TIME.
HOLD ON.
WHAT ABOUT THEIR RACE?
THE CENSUS ASKS WHAT YOUR
RACE IS I THINK IT'S CREEPY
AS HELL TO BE HONEST BECAUSE
YOUR RACE HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH ANY CHOICE THAT YOU
MADE.
SOMETHING YOU ARE BORN WITH
YOU ABOUT THE CENSUS ASKS IT
AND IT ASKS IT BECAUSE THE
LEFT DEMANDS IT ASKS IT.
DO YOU THINK THE CENSUS
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO ASK
RACE.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
SIMPLE COUNT.
NO.
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T HAVE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE LIVE IN YOUR
HOUSE?
THAT'S IT.
WHAT'S WHAT THE CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES.
IT'S ALL ABOUT ALLOCATION
AND REPRESENTATION.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT MALE
OR FEMALE.
IS THAT UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
TOO.
>> I THINK IF A PERSON WANTS
TO DESIGNATE I'M A MALE OR
FEMALE, LET THEM ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
THAT WASN'T THE QUESTION.
THE CENSUS ASKS ARE AMMAN OR ARE
THE CENSUS ASKS ARE AMMAN OR ARY
THE CENSUS ASKS ARE AMMAN OR ARU
A MAN OR WOMAN.
NON-HISPANIC WHITE.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, ARE YOU
INDIAN.
NOW IT'S GOING TO ASK ARE
YOU A CITIZEN.
ONLY ONE OF THOSE QUESTIONS
BOTHERS YOU NOT BECAUSE OF
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF IT
BUT BECAUSE YOU THINK IT
MIGHT DILUTE THE POLITICAL
POWER OF ILLEGAL ALIENS.
LET'S STOP PRETENDING IT'S
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION EYE
AGREE IT SHOULD BE COUNTING
PEOPLE NOT ON.
VOTING POWER.
THE CENSUS.
>> Tucker: DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S TAKE THE RACE
QUESTIONS OFF.
>> THE CONSTITUTION SAYS HEY
WE NEED TO COUNT PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE A MALE TORE
FEMALE, GREAT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
REPRESENTATION.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MEAN
GREAT?
SLOW DOWN.
WHY IS IT A DIFFERENCE?
IT'S A DIFFERENT STORY
BECAUSE YOU THINK IT MIGHT
DILUTE THE POLITICAL POWER
OF ILLEGAL ALIENS WHO I
COULD ADD, I'M NOT A LAWYER
LIKE YOU, SHOULDN'T BE HERE
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
BUT YOU ARE NOT BOTHERED BY
SEX OR RACE.
SO LET'S JUST STOP
PRETENDING.
LET'S DROP THE THAT SAD AND
STOP PLAYING THE STUPID GAME
WHERE WE PRETEND IT'S ABOUT
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION OF A COUNTRY
THAT YOU ARE NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO BE IN BECAUSE I
THINK YOU ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY, TOO.
IT'S ABOUT PURE POLITICAL
POWER.
IT'S ABOUT ONE SIDE TRYING
TO TAKE BACK POWER FROM THE
OTHER.
AND LIKE LET'S BE ADULTS